-Look, I cannot believe
I'm on Seth.
You know, when I --
[ Cheers and applause ]
I must tell you.
A few years ago, when I firs
came to America,
I was on
"The Ellen DeGeneres Show.
And I was so excited, I said
"I can't believe I'm on Ellen.
And she said,
"Well, technically,
you're beside me."
[ Laughter ]
-Well, I wish I had come u
with a bon mot that good.
[ Laughter ]
I do want to -- we've
interacted before,
but I didn't realize
we'd interacted before.
I -- I Instagramed a photo
of my son, and I asked --
-I follow him.
-"What are the best --
what are the best legal option
when your wife crops you
out of a photo?"
'Cause I'm wearing him
right there.
And there was a comment
from someone who said,
"Sue, sue, sue,"
named "adriennesings,"
but that's -- and that's you
-Yeah, I tried to use
Jacki Weaver,
but there were about
45 of them, and I --
[ Laughter ]
So --
-Why weren't Jacki --
'Cause I want to point out
you're adriennesings54.
[ Laughter ]
So you understood
you could put a number
at the end of something,
but you just, like, threw ou
Jacki Weaver entirely.
-That was just a nice year
1954.
-Yeah.
-I can't --
I can't claim to have been
born then.
But Adrienne was my imaginar
friend when I was a little kid
I used --
-Really?
[ Laughter ]
That's so great.
And, you know, a lot of people
outgrow their imaginary friend
and yet, here you are --
[ Laughter ]
-No.
-Here you are, you know,
still --
still keeping her alive.
-Embracing her. Yeah.
-Yeah, embracing her. That's it.
-Yeah, and she follows you
on Insta.
-She follows me on Instagram
-Yeah.
-You know, I -- you know,
sometimes I'm so proud
of the number of followers
I have,
and now I'm starting to thin
most of them might be imaginary.
[ Laughter ]
-But I love your page,
especially your babies.
-Yeah, I got good babies.
-I love babies.
-Yeah, they're really --
they're really fun.
-Yeah.
-And --
And they photograph well,
which is great,
because otherwise, out you go.
-Out, yeah.
-Yeah.
-I need the photogenic ones.
[ Laughter ]
You -- you've been filming -
we were talking backstage.
You film --
-I got very involved
when your darling wife
gave birth in the lobby.
-She gave birth in the lobby
but I heard you were very
helpful.
Did you have a --
-Oh, well, I had
a similar incident.
-Yeah, what happened?
-Well, it wasn't me.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-It was my daughter-in-law
-Your daughter-in-law.
-Yeah.
-She also couldn't make it
to the hospital?
-That's right.
-Uh-huh.
-And she -- she jumped
on the floor and said,
"Call the ambulance."
And there it was just my son
and me there and --
-Did you help out?
-I did.
-Wow.
-I caught her.
-I caught that baby.
-That's really great.
-Yeah, yeah.
-And were you nervous
when it happened?
-I was terrified.
I'd never --
it was like a million
opening nights all in one.
-Yeah.
-But she was an absolute hero,
my sister-in-law.
But the woman on the phone
you know, the dispatcher -
-Yeah.
-She said, "Well, um,
can you see the baby's head?
I said, "Yes."
She said, "Hang on, we're goin
to go through this together.
I'm staying on the phone on,
and we'll talk you through it,
and the ambos --" we --
in Australia,
we call the ambulance
people ambos.
-Well, because --
-"The ambos are on their way."
[ Laughter ]
-I will say, that's the grea
thing about Australia.
You never say a full word
if you can shorten it up.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah.
"The ambos are on their wa.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-And so, did she talk you
through it?
Were you just on the phone -
-She did.
-That's like an action movie
That's so exciting.
-It was pretty exciting,
and I was never good at --
-What was your son doing?
Was he helping?
-He was giving instruction
'cause he was talking
to the dispatcher.
-Oh, my goodness.
-And --
-Seems like he took
the easier of the two jobs
[ Laughter ]
"I'll hold the phone.
You bring life into the world.
[ Laughter ]
-He was a pale, gray color
Poor darling.
-That's great.
And everybody was healthy
and happy?
-Oh, yes. Such a beautiful
little girl who's eight now.
-Oh, my goodness.
That's fantastic.
-I don't talk about
my grandchildren much.
They don't like me to.
[ Laughter ]
I'm in a foreign country.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter and applause ]
What a delight it's been
having you here.
You have to come back soon
-I'd love to.
-Just -- just wonderful.
That's Jacki Weaver, everybody
[ Cheering ]